dans quinze jours la centrale de
tchernobyl sera enfin fermé 14 ans après
la catastrophe le réacteur numéro 3 seul
encore opérationnel a été arrêté lundi
dernier mais a repris désir soir il ne
s'agissait que d'un dysfonctionnement
électrique reste les bâtiments à haut
risque qui sous la pression
internationale seront fermés et en
mémoire l'immense tragédie qui a coûté
la vie à une partie des équipes de
secours envoyées immédiatement sur place
on les appelait les liquidateurs
reportage de notre correspondant
permanent
dominique derda ils marchent en silence
comme entouré de pente home la mine de
nikulin est à l'abandon depuis déjà
trois ans que remonter du fond quand un
beau jour de mai 1986 un ordre est
arrivé de moscou il fallait des hommes
jeunes et courageux prêts à partir de
toute urgence destination tchernobyl ce
qui les attendait là bas il n'en savait
pas grand chose il y avait tellement de
volontaires qu'il a fallu faire une
sélection ne prendre que les meilleurs
des parties d'ici à l'aube
j'avais mon boss coup puisqu'elle est
enfin tchernobyl blanche et c'est ma
valise pris ma plus belle chemise mon
plus beau pantalon
je croyais que le soir après le boulot
on irait danser en fera la fête
même s'il nous avait dit que c'était
dangereux on y serait allé malgré tout
en effet comme ça vous comprenez nous on
est les enthousiastes 12 heures
sur les 450 mineurs partis de nikulin un
tiers est mort depuis le 14 mai 18 jours
après l'explosion ils sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour contenir les fuites
radioactives
il va falloir couler une dalle de béton
sous le réacteur numéro 4 de semaine
durant sans la moindre protection
les mineurs de toul avons creusé un
tunnel dégagèrent au pas de charge des
milliers de mètres cubes de sable un
wagonnet d'une tonne et demi toutes les
deux minutes la plupart des liquidateurs
de la région de toula ceux qui ont
survécu comme sergei voronov souffre de
maux de tête de troubles du système
nerveux
la moitié d'entre eux sont invalides
mais leurs plaies les plus profondes
sont des blessures d'amour propre
les problèmes de santé c'est face à qui
nous fait souffrir le plus soit laid le
plus dur ce sont ces types là haut
ceux qui sont au pouvoir ils nous épuise
il nous tue à petit feu
il ne nous laisse même pas le temps
vivre en paix tout simplement ils ne
demandent pourtant rien d'exceptionnel
ses héros fatigué un peu de gratitude
les moyens de vivre décemment le peu de
temps qu'il en reste à vivre
l'assurance que lorsqu ils disparaîtront
leurs enfants seront à l'abri du besoin
depuis qu'il a découvert qu ivan son
fils de 11 ans était atteint de
nombreuses malformations les reins
l'oreille droite d'andrei remué ciel et
terre
en vain tous les médecins qu'on a vu
même les plus grands ils reconnaissent
que c'est bien lié à mon séjour à
tchernobyl mais aucun n'accepte de
l'écrire sur un papier est connu s'il
est handicapé parce qu'il est né avec je
sois rentré de là bas il serait normal
qu'on lui verse une indemnité mais il
faut croire que l'état n'a rien prévu
pour ça en octobre dernier une centaine
de liquidateurs sont venus à pied de
toul à moscou 200 km devant les
murailles du kremlin pour protester
contre un projet de loi qui réduirait
encore leurs indemnités qui priverait
leurs familles de pension après leur
mort ils ont jeté leurs médailles
si nous devions encore quelque chose à
notre patrie qui le président de leur
association
nous le lui avons rendu